how's government - spirit back welcome
to a game that I've been wanting to play
literally forever it's called dark souls
let's fly what the [ __ ] I don't care oh
I get to make my guy okay
oh that's smile they're here there's our
man right there beautiful and so begins
the journey of titty mac swag and we're
in the northern undead Asselin i look
pretty badass right away holy [ __ ] look
at I yeah it says attack am I supposed
to attack you but you're so nice [ __ ]
kidding what is that move shake them
titties for me girl think that doesn't
sound very good either someone is
fapping really furiously or that's gonna
be something bad in there I'm hoping for
the number one I mean - Oh it'sit's bad
either way to be honest and I want it
here what is this message yet oh [ __ ] oh
my god you're sexy
what that's a bit of a step up from the
[ __ ] first one God don't kill me
oh okay get to way got it got it
well that was [ __ ] easy I guess we're
going through the white light
it's pretty badass whoa wait wait what
hey are you doing down there
it's me it's me
Oh God Oh God it was going so well
okay think fit spots of course yes we're
you both great at breaking pots
okay just drink it just [ __ ] drink it
like a man
that is not drinking that is dying now
please time acting up with this [ __ ]
door of course not all right Yolo I
don't know what I did I'm a top of him
mom mom help fine cut all right my dog
is pooping and I can't cause what the
[ __ ] this is not bad it's inside you
poop outside man this is just like real
life
oh that helps though that helps doh
what does it say be very fun be aware
your fault well thanks thanks oh that
feels good oh that feels good ah ah
a big key [ __ ] yes oh my god I'm the
best player in the world
beware your false you [ __ ] dicks man
ever made this is a [ __ ] troll what
happens if I walk off that no don't
that was a joke [ __ ] slap [ __ ] slap
blockage and a bitch-slap wait who's
shooting me oh hey hey someone's
cheating hacks stop stop doing that I'm
gonna have to put you down oh god yes
friends stop having friends what I hear
more
god damn you guys are like a [ __ ]
high school musical oh he likes it that
guy is just standing there oh yeah oh
I'll just I'll just be alright head
let's get let's get out like a here
that's split though who you think you
are part of Spice Girls well there
haven't been cold since 1999 [ __ ] and
it was even doubtful back then why are
they doing this flips
when I die this is how I want to die who
is it
what are you like 40 party man that is
not a split man let me fix that for you
oh god damn it Jerry
no I want that one a mommy you sexy hey
mommy you sexy [ __ ] brilliant I never
seen anything like that
you [ __ ] battles look at that mess
it's beautiful oh god it feels beautiful
I don't like this oh god watch nope nope
nope nope
don't kill me please I am nice if you
get to know me I'm really good at some
results no I guess some people just
don't appreciate good eyes somersaults
it's so intense when you know if you die
you're gonna [ __ ] yeah we'll never hit
my strafing skills oh oh good luck
oh thanks appreciate it
oh god it's Rio then oh god that is so
much damage don't panic don't panic
gonna roll my somersault over here there
we go there we go alright now you guys
can have your way with me don't kill me
don't kill me and go god I can't pause
in this game don't do what are your
doing I got oh god one health don't
pierce my nipple don't don't die dad dad
I don't want to redo all
I got you distracted me that's how it's
done
[ __ ] kneel before your fabulous
master that's our buddy
hallelujah you recovered from what
trauma oh god no no it was as if I
forgot about him okay hey man not cool
okay
hey Quinta Mme
that's fine really no really it's fine
where the hell did he come from
oh thanks I cuz I didn't know that what
am i doing what am i doing
[Music]
nice fire you tobacco Bay break the soil
blocks cap oh yeah they come out
together they pull a an array habla six
toes come tally la la la rocha a bluff
it's fun for some [ __ ] reason you
have to Yolo through this [ __ ] place
hey good to see you guys good to see ya
glad a well say in your chaps bloody
okay Plan B now Plan B [ __ ] infinite
of them tired of your [ __ ] rubric I
don't care if your name is Roberto notch
that doesn't matter it's irrelevant you
guys may have heard of a gangbang but I
did not sign up for it
yo it's a Lea my problem is that I rush
through it and I don't use tactics let's
take our time and I'm sure we can do
this I do ding mama came back
oh yes diello he shells dealer in this
job blah blah blah
edu now you stay now you said you're
required mm farm okay
my father killed farmer kill da booty
video layin on o and yeah and yeah I
can't pause these [ __ ] games don't
don't test me don't test me again don't
you ever say I will test my oh the fire
I was just hoping he will do that [ __ ]
this is not even difficult I'm well
aware of that [ __ ] okay three and a half
hours later we are back I don't know
where my body is I don't like this I
should fight them here I feel like oh
yeah and that's all the time we had for
some Dark Souls today despite dying
about a gazillion times I actually
enjoyed the game it's pretty cool leave
a like if you enjoyed watching let me
know if you want more of this I don't
know I think it fits more of one video
it's this guy come Road today and I'll
see you bros in the next one say awesome
love you